EPA staffers were shocked to receive this email
obtained exclusively by CNN.
Which says “we have been directed by the
administrator to withdraw the restrictions”
The proposed protection of that pristine area
was being removed
Oh no,
that pristine area,
filled with these gorgeous salmon
will be obliterated by a mine!
At least that’s the impression you’d get watching
CNN’s 2 part “exclusive.”
I would have believed it except
I happen to have reported on that mine as part of a
special for Fox on the green tyranny
pursued by today’s rich environments.
The proposed Pebble mine is
a disaster waiting to happen.
That ad comes from one of America’s
richest environmental groups,
the NRDC,
the National Resources Defense Council.
Imagine this natural paradise destroyed.
The environmental groups ran these
ads,
they made people believe on TV that everything
was going to die.
The truth, it turns out,
is that the mine
would not even be on Alaska’ Bristol Bay.
The proposed mine, would not even be 10 miles away,
or 20 miles, or even 50 miles.
It would be 100 miles away!
Did CNN mention that?
No.
Never.
Instead, CNN made EPA director Scott Pruitt
look evil by suggesting that right after a
meeting with the mine’s boss,
he gave the mine the go-ahead.
He made that decision
without a briefing from any
of EPA’s scientists or experts.
What?
Shocking!
Without consulting scientists,
Pruitt's going to let a company massacre these fish.
But in fact, he hadn’t given the mine a green light.
He’s simply allowing
them to submit an official proposal.
Obama’s EPA had rejected the mine
before it even looked
at an environmental impact statement.
That’s unheard of.
The EPA normally asks for that environmental research,
examines it, and then
accepts or rejects it.
It doesn’t reject things without looking at them.
Pruitt’s allowing the review process to go forward
was proper.
CNN’s reporter did at least speak with the mine’s CEO,
although he sneered at the boss’s
reaction to the decision.
“It comes with no apologies"
"And do you think it was not wrong"
"that Mr. Pruitt did not even"
"look at the work even done?”
“It’s not a science decision. It’s a process decision”
This looks like the head of a gold mine
went into a new administrator and got him to reverse
what an entire department has worked on for years…”
The reporter was accurate there.
The entire department had worked on killing that mine
for years.
They had colluded with zealots
and environmental groups.
Lots of those people want no mines
built anywhere.
Don’t  believe me?
Listen to my interview with their spokesman.
There's some mines where NRDC says,
great, go ahead?
Well, it's not up to us.
Are there any?
It's not up to us to
green light mines, but what we do is...
Are there any you don't complain about?
Yeah, sure.
We asked him for some names,
we’re still waiting.
CNN also made claims like this:
The mine could potentially create a footprint
bigger than the island of Manhattan
and nearly as deep as the Grand Canyon
according to the EPA.
It could.
But it won’t.
The actual Pebble proposal is much smaller.
Pebble’s CEO is not some monster destroyer of the Earth.
He’s a Democrat who ran
environment policy for Bill Clinton and Al Gore.
CNN never mentioned that either.
Instead, the reporter called him:
"A guy who wants to mine gold
in an area that many scientists believe
will destroy one of
the most pristine sock eye salmon sporting grounds
in the whole world?
What am I missing?”
“What you’re missing is that if they’re right
then we won’t get a permit.”
Right.
But explaining that now the mine must
begin the EPA’s long and detailed environmental review
wouldn’t fit CNNs theme:
evil Trump appointee
ravages the environment.
We asked CNN,
why didn’t you mention that,
and that the mine would be 100 miles away?
They didn’t get back to us.
If environmental zealots and their sycophants
in the media get their way,
America will be a place with no mining,
No new pipelines.
No oil drilling.
No… new…anything!
People used say “NIMBY.”
You can build, just not in my backyard.
Now it’s BANANA.
Build-absolutely-nothing-anywhere-near
anybody.